ازمه تقراي التي كادت ان تعود باثيوبيا
الى عهد الحروب الاهليه الطاحنه في طريقها
الى حل كما راى مسؤولون ودبلوماسيون في
اديس ابابا بعد بدء تنفيذي اطراف الصراع
بنود الاتفاقيه ومن اهمها بدء تسليم
الاسلحه الثقيله وانسحاب قوات امهره من
تقرايه
وفود عديده تمثل مؤسسات دوليه واقليميه
قصدت اديس ابابا في الفتره الاخيره اخيرها
كانت زياره وزيرته خارجيه فرنسا والمانيا
بعد توقيع اتفاق السلامي بين الحكومه
والجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير
وتعهدت عده دول بمساعده اديس ابابا على
تحقيق العداله للمتضررين من الحرب واشترطت
التطبيعه بتحقيق العداله
فقوم الحكومه الاثيوبيه في الوقت الحالي
باعداد خطه شامله لبناء وتاهيل المناطق
المتضرره الحرب ونحن بحاجه الى المجتمع
الدولي لمساعدتنا في ايصال المساعدات
اللازمه لاعاده تاهيل واعمار المناطق
المتضرره وتسع لحكومه الاثيوبيه للاستفاده
من الوجود الدولي المتزايد في اديس ابابا
لتجفيفه بؤر التوترات وصولا الى اوضاع
افضل وتحقيق السلام الدائم في البلاد
وتقديم المتورط للعداله وايضا الجوانب
النفسيه التي تضرر بها الى المواطن وظلت
عايق كبير جدا للبعض الذي ربما قد يعاني
كثيرا جدا حتى يساعد في الاندماج وجود
دولي واممي مكثف في اثيوبيا وجهود دوليه
لدعم تنفيذ بنود اتفاقيه السلام ومساعده
المتضررين جراء الحرب في شمال البلاد
لاكثر من سنتين تجعل اثيوبيا تستعين بها
وتؤكد اتباعها لنهج الحوار والتفاوض
سعيد مزين العربيه اديس ابابا